today we are swapping snacks Korean
America you representing Team USA I'm
representing Team Korea this time what
about I'm actually not too familiar with
a lot of American snacks so we'll see
how this goes so so this is goldfish I'm
an American classic and you just got
home from school watching Pokemon on
Dragon Ball Z this is what you eat on
boy goldfish with sunglasses and he's
like yeah bruh we're babes pretty much
like a stoned goldfish that children
whatever translates to whale food so you
know whales eat everything to see they
have little you know like little crabs
prawns little starfish seaweed taste and
this is cheddar I really like this I
really like this sweet this is really
sugary it's definitely salty us
Americans are pretty salty that is not
bad very cheesy it's lighter than
bullseye right yeah it's very thick big
dance almost you can taste the seaweed
there's a little sweetness to it to it
and I also like how delicate it feels
it's like there's like nothing inside
there so it feels like there's empty air
so it feels like I'm not gaining any
calories that's what I tell myself I
couldn't eat it
wow I can not speak English that's the
point that makes you stone ideal about
go fish and get stuff yeah this is a
site like let me know if you're picking
table though doesn't really taste like
anything except what is this cheddar
it's very it's very honest about it I
load the goldfish because like the
voltage has like a visceral feeling to
me I think I'll go with this same reason
to please
very childhood how do you pronounce it
whatever hold it Bob you gotta get the
proper detail they don't [ __ ] is
represented here inclusion I think it's
a fairly for me I believe that we both
gonna agree that this is better
I think it's like sweet why I couldn't
eat a whole box of that and not feel
like trash you know salty I like salty
and cheesy perfect combination right
here
definitely feeling big we have free toes
here there's like a quart flavor to them
I've had it on hot dogs hamburgers and
in my grandma's casserole I mean truly
cheese flavor it is the best one it's
actually better than the regular one in
my opinion incurring this all comes out
which is old potato cream cheese flavor
you know like cardi B like oh dear Lord
therefore my life what's up with the
persons based on this like yeah it's
good
that's not as good as the other one
smells like feet it does do smell it
I don't smell feet very often sauce I
mean sure like the actual French version
yeah the texture is so light man oh it's
very saltiness pretty nice once you get
to it
it's really salty the saltiness and the
flavor is much more of a package it's
very peppery it's really salty
it's saltier and saltier we are salty we
are salty brand in heaven you know look
at the way the world is right now oh no
all right let's get straight to the
point here this winds sure I'm whose
name will gums up old I'm job I would go
with this one because again this is not
as over par this is this very strong
shoe love never fade this is definitely
better for me
these up Funyuns can't say I'm really
into oh you don't like onions nah man I
don't understand it I feel like every
young person favorite chips because we
love big things and what's better than
think I'm yeah I've heard of Funyuns all
my life but I've actually never had one
so I'm actually very excited to try this
this will be both of us trying to find
you for the first time why it's called
Funyuns I just got it
that is fun RINs you knew that this is
just young honey mm-hmm flavored onion
rings and it has the best like crisps
mmm good it's just the first one that
acts you like oh wow this is volume oh
yeah oh my god wow so salty boo why the
hell would you wanna mean to be sweet oh
do you eat like sugar onion am i trippin
I think onions are sweet again super
light it is good great secret that
anything is intrusive
I got taxers pom yeah yeah yeah seems
like all three Korean snacks I felt less
overpowering in terms of flavor and but
if you look at the color difference like
yeah you can see it looks lighter but
that said I actually really like this
onion flavor I think I'm actually I
prefer Funyuns I'll say Mir actually
it's more flavorful and what I would do
eat these boys oh snap oh my are the
Funyuns
my favorites are they on putting the
onion rings for sure
these are better young pudding wins
young buddy these are safe like honey in
flamin rings and this is what onion
rings are you filming I think maybe they
like less them down taste less salt less
sodium less bloating and America you
only have today
[Music]
more artistry and masterpiece I got
honey butter chip this guy right here
when you first came out this was
completely sold out they were so popular
you just couldn't get your hands on it
was like the cause this Impala yeah this
is very sweet it's the honey obviously
but I don't know how to mentally process
this I look like lace them it's giving
me the feeling I'm falling in love with
the guy in my class for the first time
Oh
hmm yeah you mess with that yesterday
that's really a pretty good you're just
sweet the sweetness makes like classy
mm-hmm yes holy she's beautiful she's
great you got money
I'm lighting up my world well I'm kind
of like tasting is butter - mm-hmm I'm
not sure if I'm a fan of that the taste
is very sophisticated the honey in a
chip I have to say this tastes a little
chunkier yeah
well that's really good going it's sunny
but it was really pulling away from me
man I got the ruffles it's for
everybody's a little bit a little more
sophisticated I think what the honey you
make throw you off as well depending on
what the palette is I'm more accustomed
to the sweet snacks because in Korea
they're mostly targeted to a younger
audience I'm gonna have to go with
ruffles on this one I'm going honey
butter all the way I'm not use this over
honey worship I'll juice honey butter
chips but I feel like I have to drink
wine and be by myself when I eat it
there's some emotional
this is one of my all-time favorite
chocolate it's I'm really into simple
candies so it's classy but it's still
cool kinda like jay-z whoa whoa oh I'm a
deep personal relationship I know
they're good but I'm actually excited
for you to try this yes I've never had
that before that was very exciting it's
a classic
this is choco pie Oh basically there's
like marshmallow in between and it's a
breading you can actually expect him up
and make a cake out of it yeah it's a
thing in Korea it's really good oh I
wasn't expecting to be that song that's
fantastic one thing you have to be
careful when you're eating shopify
literally I have like chocolate all
stuck in between my teeth I'm here today
with you guys what's the the white
that's inside is that most of us that's
the sticking point for me I do not like
marshmallows like what is this strange
flavor that's destroying an otherwise
perfect snack you like the marshmallow
yeah more smells like that really do I
have to choose one I'm gonna have to
call it time what about this beautiful
couple at the park who's about to point
or these people give me each other give
or your family gatherings or when you're
studying the electrical pie has its
meaning but tickets against video I'm
rocking with choco pie over KitKat and
that's crazy
that's a big statement I would otherwise
I feel like it's specially for like
microwave for 10 seconds
I always think about microwave or
freezing things how much s'mores that's
why mmm Vick more like
Wow someone call her mother in class you
know you're not supposed to eat in class
if we eat this I'll just out of the
packaging it would make noise and give
the crumbs would you like kind of like
crushing it making it into a little like
marshmallow chocolate bread mixture into
a little poop like figure and then we're
just like oh my give me a think about
give me think about that still
marshmallow it tastes better like that